[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors comme vous pouvez voir elle a déjà
réenchanter son monde c'est bon
alors tu peux nous parler un petit peu
de toi parce que bon excuse-moi nous on
te connaît dans dans ce que tu as fait
les médias sociaux et tout mais qui tu
es alors qui je suis bah déjà pour ceux
qui me connaissent pas j'ai fait
l'émission le meilleur pâtissier sur M6
mais au-delà de ça je pense être une
belle personne avec les bons et les
mauvais côtés comme tout le monde et
d'ailleurs je vous invite aussi à vous
dire tous dans la salle que vous êtes de
belles personnes parce qu'on ne le dit
pas assez c'est important ça fait du
bien au moral merci
ça commence par soi même c'est bien
c'est important OK et bah tu dis ok tu
es une belle personne mais dis-nous un
petit peu plus je pense quand même être
quelqu'un de David enfin d'être créatif
intéressé par la ville les gens être
punaise sensible j'ai envie de découvrir
le monde et je pense même être un peu
étrange parfois et je sais je pense que
c'est ce qui fait que mon parcours est
atypique ok bah parle-nous de ce
parcours atypique est-ce que tu as
commencé dans la pâtisserie tu as
travaillé avec un grand chef comment ça
se passe pas du tout je commence par
faire comme tout le monde le bac que je
décide de faire en alternance chez moi
la maison mais je m'y retrouve pas je je
sais pas je sais pas ma place et dans ce
laps de temps mon papa qui
qui est dans un dans notre maison un sel
un four à bois et je me suis dit mais en
fait c'est ça je vais faire je vais
faire de la pizza
c'est parti donc je me lance j'achète
j'achète un frigo des bâches avec mes
origines je me dis bah j'ai l'impression
italienne espagnole donc ça tombe bien
je me suis dit que la pizza c'était un
peu ancré en moi donc ça me paraissait
logique et j'ouvre ma pizzeria dans le
garage de mes parents OK
un peu à l'arrache
c'est toute ma vie d'ailleurs je j'ouvre
ça et
à côté de ça je j'ai une deuxième
passion qui est la plongée parce que mon
papa s'appelle Neptune donc vous voyez
Neptune plongée c'est à peu près logique
que je fasse de la plongée et je passe
mon premier niveau en gravière en Alsace
mais j'ai quand même deux grands rêves
dans la vie le premier c'était d'être à
mon compte et le deuxième c'était faire
le tour du monde donc ni deux je prends
un billet d'avion j'ai ma maman bon bah
dans trois mois salut je pars en
Australie et c'est ce que j'ai fait je
suis partie toute seule en Australie
avec mon billet d'avion sans parler
anglais je suis arrivé sur place j'ai
continué un peu mon trajet et je me suis
dit que si déjà j'allais jusqu'au bout
du monde fallait que je continue un peu
ma route donc j'ai fini par atterrir à
Bali où je suis devenu monitrice de
plongée donc pizza plongée on est
d'accord qu'il y a tout à fait un lien
d'ailleurs je pense que on voit voilà on
me voit quand je fais de la plongée
c'est c'était un moment incroyable c'est
riche je pense que ça fait partie des
moments où j'ai vu les plus belles
choses de ma vie en fait sous l'eau
c'est vraiment un je le souhaite à tout
le monde de vivre une expérience comme
ça mais encore une fois si déjà je
traverse la planète je pouvais pas
m'arrêter juste à ça donc je continue ma
route et je traverse toute l'Asie du
Sud-Est
et je finis par rentrer en Alsace où je
vais ouvrir ma deuxième pizzeria
tu le fais toute seule avec un compagnon
qui dit ce voyage tout ça de sac à dos
mon voyage moi et moi-même mon sac à dos
mes chaussures et pas grand chose dans
mon sac c'était parti retour en Alsace
retour en Alsace j'ouvre ma deuxième
pizzeria donc voilà
mon premier bébé une pizzeria une vraie
avec des couverts des employés enfin la
totale on n'est pas dans le garage on
est sur quelque chose un peu plus posé
je pose mes valises et je me dis bah
voilà je j'ai toujours fait de la pizza
je vais continuer à faire de la pizza
je m'arrêter là vous pensez bien je
décide de un jour d'aller voir le cirque
Arlette Gruss et puis sur un coup de
tête moi mon chien je me suis dit bah
tiens je vais acheter une caravane et je
suis parti faire le cirque
donc pas longtemps deux trois mois mais
je voulais voir ce que c'était un peu et
la pizzeria toujours j'avais une mes
employés étaient sur place et je leur ai
dit bon bah écoute c'est moi ça me prend
trop bien je vais aller faire deux trois
mots aussi que je reviens donc je suis
ma caravane je suis parti et
me revoilà avec toujours ma pizzeria
mais encore une fois j'avais pas
m'arrêter là un jour je regardais la
télé et puis je vois passer le casting
du meilleur pâtissier
ça aussi je vais faire
parce que vous le savez pas mais j'ai
l'impression de la cuisine et de la
pâtisserie même si j'en fais pas
beaucoup je me suis dit voilà j'allais
faire ça vraiment comme ça j'aime me
suis inscrite j'ai été sélectionné et
j'allais dire par le plus grand des
miracles mais j'ai quand même travaillé
un peu j'ai remporté le concours je me
sens que voilà bah voilà c'est moi
merci
et bien super super c'est un parcours
impressionnant riche parce que quand on
voit ces photos là ou quand on te suit
dans les médias sociaux on peut penser
que c'est focus pâtisseries mais c'est
une vie qui est colorée qui est riche
on a même l'impression que tu peux tout
faire maintenant tu as envie de d'aller
sur Mars tu convaincras Elon Musk
d'aller sur Mars on se voit ça peut être
possible mais forcément il arrive
toujours un moment où
ben ça pêche d'accord et au moment où ça
pêche tout simplement c'est parce que
après le meilleur pâtissier il y a eu le
covid le confinement on a été
ce que je vous ai dit
le confinement et la pression des médias
sociaux qu'on s'imagine pas du tout donc
moi j'ai pas été très embêté mais la
pression qu'on se met qu'on s'infilge en
fait à soi-même et très difficile donc
j'ai un peu sombré comme un poisson dans
un bocal c'est assez difficile il
fallait trouver une façon de s'en sortir
c'était c'est éprouvant en fait et
comment tu as fait malgré ma famille
mais d'ailleurs ça va me faire pleurer
mais ma famille
c'est Jean-Charles extrastockage il est
là merci pour le soutien
j'ai plus enfin j'ai trois choses qui
m'animent dans la vie c'est voyager
cuisiner et ma famille malgré le soutien
de ma famille j'ai quand même pas réussi
tout de suite à trouver le la lumière et
ce petit déclic a commencé par ma fille
qui m'a demandé un jour des œufs pour
Pâques
ok bon bah si déjà j'ai fait de la pizza
de la plongée du cirque je préfère des
chocolats et je décide de faire des
chocolats qui sont pas à la main donc
qui sont entièrement pas à la main très
colorés et là quand je démoule mes
chocolats je me rends compte que c'est
c'est ça en fait elle est là la lumière
en fait elle est là le la lumière du
bout du tunnel et d'ailleurs en fait
je sais pas qui est la plus belle du
chocolat ou de ma fille mais j'ai ma
fille
et en fait quand j'ai découvert cette
joie déjà pour elle et pour moi de du
chocolat de la création de
l'épanouissement en fait c'est comme si
vous retrouvez à Noël tous les jours je
vais vous démouler un chocolat c'est
Noël donc c'est super on est toujours
content donc j'ai vécu enfin j'ai vu une
lumière j'ai vu quelque chose qui
m'animait qui me faisait vibrer je pense
que c'était c'était ça en fait c'était
ça la lumière
donc voilà je c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de changer de métier d'accord
mais j'aimerais quand même faire une
légère aparté c'est que j'aimerais
transmettre un message je vous souhaite
et je vous le dis n'ayez jamais peur des
changements dans la vie parce que peu
importe ce que les gens vont dire
l'essentiel c'est que si vous en
ressentez le besoin vous pourrez
toujours vous épanouir par la suite je
dis pas que c'est facile mais je dis que
le plus difficile c'est le premier pas
une fois qu'on le premier pas est fait
on peut que être épanoui dans sa vie
excellent excellent excellent alors tu
nous as prévu
je sais pas je sais pas qui sont les
heureux chanceux qui vont qui ont prévu
de rester pour la soirée qui reste pour
la soirée
vous allez avoir d'extraordinaire c'est
quoi qu'est-ce que tu nous a prévu donc
j'ai prévu pour cette soirée un
tableau donc c'est un tableau de près on
se rend pas compte mais il fait 2 m et
il est entièrement réalisé sur mesure
pour pour l'événement à l'image de ce
que je souhaite transmettre donc la joie
et la couleur donc on voit bien j'ai mis
le paquet j'ai fait pareil pour le
tableau et il y a une partie qui se
mange donc en fait on se rend pas compte
mais tous les petits cubes sont des
pattes de fruits donc il y en a 130 donc
il y en a une patte de frites pour
chaque personne c'est c'est ça en fait
mon ma joie mon plaisir c'est à travers
deux axes je fais des master class pour
les particuliers où on apprend à faire
des chocolats comme on pourra le voir
ici par exemple
des chocolats colorés tout se mange
effectivement ok très bien on aura le
droit à ça non on va voir des pattes de
fruits mais aussi coloré donc ça c'est
pour les particuliers et je fais des
tableaux pour les événements les
entreprises pour voilà pour partager
animé se régaler et
s'il y avait un la fin qu'est-ce que tu
nous dirais mon mot de la fin ce serait
bah life is beautiful et soyez heureux
mais en couleur
[Applaudissements]